Charles Ogletree jr. where does the
title all deliberate speed come from it
actually comes from the second case in
Brown versus Board of Education the
first case that we all know about was
decided on May 17 1954 but after the
Supreme Court said we have to end
segregation and had a second decision to
decide how to implement that on May 31st
1955 it said we're going to end
segregation but we're going to do so
with all deliberate speed and that
became my mantra the idea that Brown was
a colossal very important decision but
the second Brown decision to implement
it took away much of the moral courage
and the force of the first decision who
was Brad and who was the Board of
Education what was interesting the brown
Oliver Brown was the father of Linda
Brown a young african-american girl from
Topeka Kansas she was concerned that she
had to walk a long distance from her
home to go to school because she was
black and the n-double-a-cp with the
great leadership of Charles Hamilton
Houston harvard-educated lawyer and
Thurgood Marshall and others looked
around the country and they found five
places the case is called Brown versus
Board of Education it's as Oliver Brown
against the Topeka Board of Education
but it's five cases the n-double-a-cp
brought cases in Virginia but in
Delaware in South Carolina but also in
Topeka Kansas and in the District of
Columbia so it was a concerted effort to
say Supreme Court this time you cannot
duck the question of separate but equal
education we're showing you this is a
national phenomenon
and Brown versus Board of Education is
the name of a case that's actually five
cases would you be sitting here without
this case not at all why I I might be
cleaning up here or doing something else
but I wouldn't be sitting here as a
professor at Harvard Law School my
entire life is influenced by this case
when the Supreme Court integrated public
education and created opportunities for
me from my little hometown in Merced
California I'm sure it had a big impact
on my ability to go to Stanford
University even though I did end up
graduating with honors it had a
absolutely significant impact on my
going to Harvard Law School and being a
tenured faculty member there now
I was not the first qualified or the
most capable
it's just that others had made
sacrifices and I stand on those broad
shoulders I would not be here I could
not be here but for the sacrifices of
great teachers and the great lawyers who
made these cases a reality you have this
double size picture in the middle of
your book would the who are these folks
and would they be where they are today
without brown berg you know some of them
might say that they would because those
are all Harvard Law School graduates and
they all hundred they're all African
American graduates from Harvard Law
School from the 1960s until the year
2000 and we held for the first time ever
in Harvard's history a gathering of all
of its African American law graduates it
was a celebration that's what was called
a celebration of Harvard's black alumni
and the goal was to say let's just take
a look at what has happened and it tells
you that Harvard Law School
has had a profound impact on the ability
of African Americans to have upward
mobility in many places and it goes
beyond that this picture exemplifies
other greats who were there Ken Chenault
who's the president of American Express
he is a Harvard Law School graduate
Frank Range the president Fannie Mae
another Harvard Law School graduate
Loretta R Grant who was the head of the
tax division Clinton ministration
Harvard Law School graduate these
african-americans have had incredible
mobility because of those opportunities
seven of us are on the faculty now I've
taught students who are teachers now
partners in law firms the leaders in
business and industry so Brown opened up
doors that weren't imaginable that
picture could not have been taken ten
years ago or 20 years ago or 30 years
ago but now it's a celebration we've
arrived and it's no time to look back or
to go back put on still store we call
them the names of the members of the
Supreme Court back then and there on the
screen here just a second first one on
that list is Hugo black and it shows the
stadiums from originally the years that
he served and he was there 34 off to the
right Stan Stanley read Felix
Frankfurter William O Douglas Robert
Jackson who William Rehnquist
for the exactly right Harold Burton of
Ohio Tom Clark of Texas Ramsey Clark his
son became Attorney General right
Sherman Menten from Indiana and Chief
Justice Earl Warren of California
anything about that particular court
that's important to know well what's
about that court that's important it's
an eclectic court you know Hugo black
was justice who was appointed people
were concerned about his former ties to
the Ku Klux Klan he disavowed that those
when he joined the court he was one who
was very concerned about rights during
the Warren court era when he was there
but what's missing actually is for Ed
Vincent that's the sort of untold story
of the court that was going to decide
Brown was a radically different court in
disposition in 1953 the judges were
split entirely and ideologically and
whether or not they would in Plessy
versus Ferguson in 1896 philosophy a
doctrine of separate but equal and it's
reported based on memoranda held by the
justices man that Chief Justice Fred
Vincent from Kentucky was one of the
five who would uphold Plessy and not
integrate the school's amazingly on
September 8th 1953 after the court had
the case had been argued they were
waiting for decision Fred Vinson died
and it was clear that Felix Frankfurter
Harvard Harvard Law School professor and
member of the court it was very bright
did not like Vinson it's reported that
he said at the time of Vincent's death
his chief justice in the colleague he
said this is the first indication that
I've ever had that there is a god that's
a pretty strong statement for one just
as about another and Vincent's death
allowed Earl Warren to join the court
Warren had been the governor of
California he was the Attorney General
during the Korematsu the internment of
japanese-americans during the Second
World War but Eisenhower thought that he
would be a person who could bring
consensus and that is exactly what he
did and it's hard to imagine another
Chief Justice who's had so much success
and bringing this disparate points of
view together and what Warren did was to
talk to the justices try to alleviate
differences and to say we need to speak
with one more
and up until May 17th 1954 there was not
a single voice there were many voices
some wanted to write descents someone to
write concurring opinions but Chief
Justice Earl Warren took his time the
politician that he was to go justice by
justice to understand their fears and to
get them to come with unanimous decision
it made all the difference in the world
that in 1954 after 58 years of Jim Crow
segregation the Supreme Court said with
one voice separate but equal is
inherently unequal there were two
decisions as you say brown one and brown
to go over what did brown one do again
may 17 1954 what what brown one did to
say right now we are proclaiming for
once and forever that segregation as we
knew it
that was operative and legal is ended
today
the question was and how do we implement
this what do we tell all the various
states whether we tell all the schools
well we tell the federal courts what do
we tell them and say we want additional
arguments justice frankfurter was
particularly concerned about how do we
do this there's going to be southern
resistance there's going to be reactions
we don't know how we can enforce this
without thinking about it let's hear
arguments in terms of what's the remedy
the right is to equal education the
remedy is how fast Thurgood Marshall and
the lawyer said it should be forthwith
you've made a bold decision now support
it by saying and segregation now the
court came back on May 31st a year later
and said we are going with these orders
to end segregation and it said with all
deliberate speed
the lawyers didn't even quite realize
what had happened right it when that
originally happened and there was a
secretary who went and look at the word
deliberate and learned that there were
deliberate made slow and so the Supreme
Court was saying we'll end segregation
but it will be done slowly and in West
law governor Faubus in Arkansas stood in
the door said black children not going
to come to Central High School governor
Wallace has said segregation today
segregation tomorrow segregation forever
at the same time there was this thing
called the southern manifesto members of
all Congress came together and said that
we're going to fight this
for integration by any means necessary
at the same time even Dwight D
Eisenhower would appointed Chief Justice
Warren was disappointing
by saying that all these southern whites
want is for their sweet little southern
girls to not be in classroom with some
big overgrown Negroes and he said you
can't change people's minds or hearts
through long if the chief executive of
the country is not committed to this
decision you can imagine how easy it was
for others to resist it
to his credit ultimately in 1958 he was
prepared to call in the airborne to
ensure that Central High was integrated
so Eisenhower ultimately decided it
would be in force but he was ambivalent
about whether or not the south in
particular was ready for integration I
want to show the court one more time for
folks that didn't get a chance to see
the entire court anybody on there on
this list and we'll show you go black
here at the top that surprises you there
was a nine zeroes it both both brown one
around two nine zero right at both were
unanimous decisions there are a lot of
surprises just as Douglass seemed very
clear that he thought that frankfurter
was ambivalent he thought he had a few
of the votes but some of the justices
just weren't ready when you talk about
justice Burton whether or not he was
really ready for a you meant unanimous
decision and there were constant
arguments going back and forth the same
was said about justice Reed and so there
were debates about who would finally
support the decision but Earl Warren has
to be given credit for being the
ultimate and consummate politician to
take nine men and work this amazingly
well two of my mentors and colleagues at
Harvard Law School clerked for
frankfurter that year one Frank sander
is still on the Harvard Law School
faculty the other Jim borne Berg our
former dean recently died but he was
also on the faculty and they talked
about the court keeping this entire case
almost secret law clerks didn't work on
it they weren't involved in it the court
didn't want the word to slip out they
thought this decision was very
controversial in the highly volatile and
they did not really share it with their
law clerks until just before it was
in fact Frank Sanders says frankfurter
told him or you might want to come into
the courtroom today on May 17th but did
it didn't tell him then what had to
happen and the ultimate decision so this
was a very significant decision and the
other thing is when you read about it if
you read law cases if you pull up law
cases you see that legal jargon the
technical jargon it seems to me that
this decision was really written for the
public because it's straightforward it's
not complicated it doesn't have a lot of
citations it's a very short decision as
is the second Braun to and I think the
court was trying to make a says have a
message that here we have this issue of
segregation here we have clear disparity
between the schools for blacks and
whites and we have to send a message out
that's clear and unambiguous and not
tied up in legal jargon that's exactly
what they did and that was 1955 May the
second decision when's the first thing
that happened in this country that made
a difference for black kids and either
in the south or the north well it's hard
to tell because let me tell you what
didn't happen there was no wholesale
embracing of this decision in fact there
was resistance and Arkansas there's a
case called
Aaron versus Cooper decided in 1958
because in Arkansas there was this
constant effort to refuse to Governor
Faubus another refused to integrate and
the Supreme Court in 1958 came back and
said we're demanding that you do this
right now and they were they knew that
they had Eisenhower support that is that
if we tell them they must do it mr.
president
you have to make sure you're prepared to
send troops and that's exactly what
happened so even years after the
decision they were still resistance
ultimately by the 60s and 70s you start
seeing substantial evidence of
integration in the South one the reason
is this book was written was because one
of my points is that we keep thinking
the problem of segregation was a
southern problem it was a national
problem because as much as we saw every
night on TV in the 50s and 60s
demonstrations in Birmingham and in
Selma
in Jackson Mississippi and all parts of
the south 21 years after brown I'm on my
way to law school at Harvard Law School
in 1975 and what do we have we have
white resistance to integrated education
in the city of Boston it's black
children were victims of all sorts of
intolerance by whites who felt that
blacks were being you know forced upon
them and I was amazed to see as a young
man going to law school that there were
still resistance in the 1970s to
integrated education this is a little
bit ahead of the story but tell the
story about you and your wife arriving
in Boston well it's amazing because we
left California we were married in the
summer of 1975 and we do something about
Boston but we drove to Boston we'd
rented an apartment found by a friend of
ours of Larry Terry who's a medical
student at Harvard Medical School
and when we arrived there of that fall
it was quite amazing as we got there got
directions got screwed up and so I ended
up getting off the highway I 93 which is
a main thoroughfare in Boston and I
called our landlord telling him I wasn't
quite there and explained where we were
and he said describe where you are and I
said well those there's Paddy's liquors
and there's O'Reilly so on and so he
said get back in the car
just get back in the car and find the
freeway what he was telling me is that
we had inadvertently driven into South
Boston the very area where they'd been
racial violence from 1974 1975 and we
finally got back on the highway made it
into Cambridge found our little
apartment in East Cambridge and then I
realised that this was not just a fairy
tale that wasn't something to read about
in the newspapers I was there in the
middle of a crisis in 1975 concerning
busing and racial conflict between
blacks and whites go back to the
courtroom in 1954 and 55 who were the
lawyers or the lawyer that stood up in
front of that court and argued the case
well let me go a little bit further back
because the most important lawyer wasn't
there the lawyer who was responsible for
the Brown case the architect of the
decision is Charles Hamilton Houston
he was from Washington DC with the
Amherst College he's a graduate of
Harvard Law School he was the first
african-american to be elected to the
Harvard Law Review which is an honor in
terms of academic performance he also in
addition to being one of the great
geniuses he could not find a job in a
law firm because of his race isn't this
a portrait here of him in this one
picture exactly a Harvard Law School in
1998 had a tribute to Charles Hamilton
Houston and his family came back in his
son who lives in Baltimore and his
grandson who's a lawyer in Arizona and
as and as granddaughter were all part of
the celebration but he couldn't get a
job and he went back to Washington
worked with his father's law firm and
ultimately went to Howard law school to
teach and he trained Thurgood Marshall
the lawyer who argued the brown case he
trained Oliver Hill 97 year old lawyer
who argued one of the brown cases and he
trained the next generation of lawyers
to fight segregation there's a video
called the road to Brown which
chronicles Houston's incredible efforts
to integrate the south and many people
say that he killed Jim Crow because of
all of his efforts they don't my own
view is that Jim Crow might have killed
him he died prematurely
he was just fifty years old when he died
in 1950 so before the brown case was
even argued he died but every lawyer
there Thurgood Marshall Robert Carter
spots with Robinson
Oliver Hill Jack greenberg whole James
neighbor'ood George EC Hayes all these
lawyers in Moore had been trained or
influenced by Houston so he didn't argue
but the people who were there were his
law his pupils who was Jim Crow Jim Crow
was a caricature and there was a
character of a sort of shuffling in sort
of an embarrassing character in African
American black white and black face and
but Jim Crow was the institution and the
Jim Crow wasn't a person it was a
caricature but the institution was to
show the difference between blacks and
whites and what what's amazing that once
we ended slavery the 18
the response was to say blacks are free
but they're not equal because we
immediately started the process of
implementing a Jim Crow system saying
that you are free but you have to drink
at separate water fountains you have to
live in separate communities you have to
work in different places you don't have
certain basic fundamental rights of
citizens because we're going to separate
you by the race it's what we call
apartheid in South Africa separation of
the races and it was prevalent in many
respects around the country up through
the time of the Supreme Court's decision
in 1954 and it really didn't end right
away it continued that day you have this
picture out front in your book and who's
in there these are all the lawyers who
played a role not all of them it's a
number of the lawyers who played a
prominent role in the brown case is it's
a thurgood marshall he's joined by
Spotswood robinson you've got bill
Coleman you've got George reading you've
got George EC Hayes and a number of the
other lawyers who all worked on the case
I Jack green works there as well a
number the other lawyers who were
involved like William Coleman's not
their constituent Motley's not there but
a lot of lords who were in Washington
came to stand on the steps of the
Supreme Court after the case was decided
you say somewhere in your book that your
father didn't when when it talks about
history that he wouldn't have known who
Thurgood Marshall was but would have
known who Martin Luther King was well
and that that was a common that's the
case today if you go into any public
school black or white you ask him about
Martin Luther King it's a national
holiday and most people know about that
if you ask my Thurgood Marshall most
people don't have a clue
even most law students don't have a clue
because Thurgood Marshall was such a
factor in the law but not publicly known
and indeed I have a chapter in the book
talking about this tension between
Marshall and King and Thurgood Marshall
told an amazing story after he won the
case got in a cab with a black cab
driver go on to another part of town in
Washington cab driver said you hear the
good news he said what's that young man
he says well we won the Supreme Court
today Oh what happened says Martin
the king won the civil rights movement
and Thurgood Marshall just had two grand
here he was having won this case and
Martin the King was again getting credit
and I talked about the the the jealousy
envy the conflict between the two codes
Marshall believed in the law strongly
that the law you had to work through the
court system to make it work and dr.
King believed that the law was unjust it
was morally reprehensible and that you
had to change the law by forcefully
nonviolent force by extrajudicial means
and Marshall talked about having to
represent Kay and get him out of trouble
etc and that there was his tension and
the reality is that they both were
important that the it was important to
win in court but though these decisions
weren't self effective that is that you
had to have a mechanism to make them
work and so every time a case was won
there still was a necessity go into the
community and make it work
it said separate but equal ended in 1954
but the same year in 1955 in Montgomery
Rosa Parks was arrested for sitting and
a section reserved for whites on a bus
in Montgomery Alabama the same year a
young man named Emmett Till a teenager
at left Chicago went down to Mississippi
whistled at a white woman he was lynched
so America hadn't changed in significant
ways decade later in 1963 dr. King came
here gave the incredible speech in the
march on Washington we only want to
remember his first half of the speech
where he says I have a dream but if you
read his entire speech he says there is
a nightmare it's not a dream today it's
a nightmare he says I'd like my son to
be judged by the care by the content of
his character not the color of his skin
but the reality in 1963 his son was
still judged by the color of his skin
you talked about police brutality he
talked about the government writing a
bad check for African Americans with
insufficient funds he talked about a
Negro in Mississippi could not vote in
Negros and New York didn't have anyone
to vote for so he talked about he came
to complain about what was happening in
America
in the 1963's so even though 93 even
though we've made incredible progress
there still was resistance to the idea
of changing our nation and all
deliberate speed carries from 54 in many
respects it still is current in some
aspects of our slow progress toward true
integration and true opportunity where
did you get the idea to write that at
this book the idea came from a number of
sources first I wanted folks to know
that those of us who have made it
shouldn't try to suggest that we've made
it on our own that I knew that there
were giants on whose shoulders I stand
and I knew that I could I could be the
highest possible pinnacle at Harvard Law
School I could go to a private
institution like Stanford University I
can serve them Stanford's Board of
Trustees I could have all this
prominence but indeed I knew that I only
made it because Thurgood Marshall and
Robert Carter and Constance Baker motley
and Oliver Hill and Jack Greenberg and
Bill chrome and all the others open up
the doors
that's why number one to show that I
none of us would have made it without
that change the second point is that as
we celebrate the fiftieth anniversary
may 17th 2004 we have to recognize that
a lot of work needs to be done because
today in the 21st century many of the
schools that were challenged for
segregation in 1950s are more integrated
now a more segregated now than they were
50 years ago so we have not achieved the
goal that Marshall or Charles Hamilton
Houston or any of the other lawyers had
in mind the second reason I wrote the
book was that it's very interesting to
see the change in the court from
Marshalls time when he was a lawyer
arguing cases in winning 29 out of 32
cases or Robert Carter winning 21 out of
22 Supreme Court cases those were
extraordinary accomplishments that I
want to show that this dream team we've
never had a group of Africa merican
lawyers as successful or as committed to
public interest as we had in the 30s 40s
and 50s and they've set a high-water
mark and I'm challenging all of us who
come after them to say we too must take
on
the awesome challenge of trying to
promote equality in our country and that
we have a high standard to meet made by
these lawyers and the final reason for
the book was to let young people know
particularly young African Americans but
all young people to know that everyone
can make a difference I come from a very
humble background we grew up in poverty
we were on public welfare
my parents were seasonal workers I
worked in the fields of when I was a kid
picking peaches and almonds at picking
cotton all that was part of my life in
California in the 1950s and early 60s
and that where you start has no
reflection on where you will end and I
wanted to say that they were proud
people my grandparents who grew up in
Arkansas my parents from Mississippi
from Arkansas and Alabama
they came from humble surroundings but
they were proud and focused on education
and made sure that even though they
didn't succeed my father finished only
the fourth grade my mother only went to
the tenth grade education was always
talked about in our home and they want
to make sure that if they could not make
it in segregated south of the 1930s and
40s that there are children once we were
born in the 50s and 60s would have a
better opportunity and indeed that's
that's why to salute those parents who
made the ultimate sacrifice for their
children to have opportunities in the
20th century after you graduated from
Harvard Law School came to Washington
became a public defender and were about
to be sworn in as someone who could
argue before the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court Bar you invited your
father to come and your father hadn't
been at your Stanford graduation or your
Harvard right what happened
it never was clear to me what was going
on my father was a very proud man but he
also was very I think embarrassed by his
lack of success I'm graduating from
Stanford with honors
my wife is graduating from Stanford and
my father who would plan to come didn't
show up and I'm sure his feeling was
what can I say this is your father and
mother
exactly 1982 after my sister had been
murdered
his point was that he's just a poor
working-class guy and he couldn't say he
went to school anywhere he couldn't say
done anything of accomplishment so he
was very embarrassed by that and the
same thing of law school now I'm not
just a college graduate but I'm a lawyer
now had graduate from Harvard and it
just was too much for him to take and I
was very disappointed and so I worked
with my cousin's the moral Ogletree
eggleston to try to get her father who
had been separated from my father since
they were young they were both men and
their 70s and then they had left Alabama
both and they had not been together in
40 years and so she was able to persuade
her father to come from Buffalo New York
here to Washington where I was a public
defender and I talked to my mother and
father that come from California to come
to my swearing-in I thought would be
important to be in the Supreme Court
Thurgood Marshall was there and again
what day was it May 31st
1983 which again was the anniversary of
the all deliberate speed may 31st 1955
so 28 years after that decision I'm in
the Supreme Court being sworn in and the
night before my father called me and
said Jr I can't come I said oh my god I
remembered College our amendment law
school what would he say now I was not
going to go for it this was the you know
I bought him a suit that's nice shoes he
was all traveled ready to go the tickets
were there mother was there ready to go
I said he can't come he said why I said
why can't you come he says I don't have
a hat excuse me he says I don't have a
hat says I've got all these nice things
but I don't have a hat I can't travel
without a hat I was furious I didn't
know what that meant it made no sense to
me that my father now had a
eleventh-hour excuse I talked to my
mother called our local department store
in Merced they were able to take the
information over the phone and she went
down with him and he got a hat and he
flew out here and but it was amazing he
would not have come without the Hat but
that hat was a metaphor that I have a
lot of pride but I'm not quite as proud
as I could be son and if I'm going to be
there on your day
I need to look right he was gonna be the
other seaters color lawyer Thurgood
Marshall and so it was a major event for
him and I never understood at that
moment but then something else occurred
Brian that really struck me I noticed
when I started looking back dr. King
often wore a hat Thurgood Marshall often
wore a hat it was a sign of power a sign
of respect a sign of courage that black
men wore these hats what I didn't know I
went back and looked at my college
photos almost every photo I was in and
everything that I was doing I had a head
I didn't even know I liked hats but I
had had somehow mysteriously adopted
this philosophy of worn a hat until the
book actually has a picture of my father
and his brother coming to the Supreme
Court in their brand-new hats with their
brand-new suits and they could not have
been too proud or black men then on that
day on May 31st 1983 and it's amazing to
see them grinning and smiling which
lungi dance on the right my father's the
one on the right with the brown hat that
matches his nice brown suit and his
brother as the one closest to me so it's
me my uncle and my father and they were
this has taken in the Supreme Court we
took a photograph there before we left
and they spent time at my house that
week it was amazing for him to hear them
tell stories about growing up about
stealing miss Delmas fruit over the tree
or little things I did as kids and they
were remembering Alabama the most
positive moments and never really
talking about the segregation except
they did tell one story that sort of
stunned me that they believed that it
was a crime for a black man to look a
white woman in the eye and I never said
that because my father always would
would not look at he looked he would not
look you in the eye he would he would
sort of look askance I never understood
what that was when he did that with
white people and then I found a case in
Alabama that finally made me understand
what they were talking about there was a
1951-52 McWhorter versus state a case
where an African American
was walking by there was a white woman
and did he glanced at her did he say
something - or what he was charged with
and convicted of assault with intent to
commit rape never touched her and so you
could you know how the urban legend
carries so the word was a black man
looking at a white woman is a crime and
these men believed that to their death
and it's amazing that they felt that way
about the system but it also tells you
something about the South they grew up
in in the thirties in the 40s and why
they both decided to leave Alabama to go
to New York in the California he died
how soon after that well the father died
the next year we were sworn in May 31st
1983 he died on st. Patrick's Day March
17th 1984 what were the circumstances of
the murder of your sister it was a very
tragic case and it's still a tragic case
this happened in August 1982 my sister
was a police officer she actually worked
in her hometown she was where was that
in Merced California she was the most
loyal of us as each of us got an
education opportunity we left Merced I
went to Stanford my two younger brothers
joined the Air Force and were career
members of the Air Force
my younger sister got married and moved
but Barbra Jean opal tree Scoggins was a
police officer and she and I were always
teasing each other by our professions
I'm a defense lawyer getting people off
and she's a police officer locking
people up and what we talked about was
the fact that as much as we tease each
other that we both had values that were
respected by the other I respected the
fact that even though she was a police
officer she would help people make calls
to reach their family she would lend
people money she would get people rides
home if they couldn't get home when they
were released she was one a very kind
and caring member of the Mercer County
Sheriff's Department and in August
August 17th 1982 she didn't report to
work and later that day her co-workers
came to her house came in there had been
no forcible entry they found her lying
on the floor
stabbed having bled to death that
stabbed in the heart and her
three-year-old son
Alex was lying right there next to her
was crime and so it was a tragic
circumstance it changed my whole
philosophy about what I was doing
because I've been a public defender for
five years by then and it made me feel
victimized for the first time and I
started figuring out I asked my mother
what did they know who do they find who
have they questioned what's the evidence
and I became a zealous victim wanting to
figure out why my sister who had done
nothing had been murdered and it was a
very tough moment for the family because
we've never gotten an answer
I placed awards rewards out for
information we have memorials there and
as much as we have a sense of who might
be responsible that's not a way that the
criminal justice system works I even had
a friend of mine Jay Stevens he was a
prosecutor here in Washington in the US
Attorney's Office and we tried cases
together and after Jay had left the
office he was the US attorney I asked
him whether the Justice Department could
look into my sister's murder and he told
me well it's not a federal crime it
doesn't have any initiative he did he
looked but nothing was there I just
wanted it resolved and I had hoped it
would be resolved while my parents were
alive my father died in 1984 and my
mother died 2001 and so neither of them
were able to at least come to peace with
the fact that my sister their daughter
had been murdered and the case is still
unsolved where's the little
three-year-old he's in California has he
done he said he's doing fine he's
working now my aunt
Nadine Washington has been very active
with him and Alex such as name is Alex
such Scoggins is a hard-working young
man and getting his life together and he
had he has no memory that's the sad part
three years old he knows that his mother
was gone but you can imagine what it was
being there and not being able to help
and try to clarify something but they
tried
and the police officers I mean this is a
town that I grew up in the Chief of
Police is somebody who I played football
with this is a the we're all part of the
same community and so it is still tough
and they get my annual call saying Tony
decided to what do you know now what can
you tell me now and they said Charlie
we're still looking we're trying to find
something but you know it's a cold case
we can't find anything to warm it up but
I'm never going to forget about it and
I'm never going to let it go Merced
California is where it really is in the
San Joaquin Valley it's in the central
part of California it's the farm country
when you're talking about California
people think of Los Angeles Southern
California they think of San Francisco
Northern California there's a vast land
in between and that's where I grew up
that's where I and all my brothers and
sisters were raised but this picture
right here that's my school with one of
my favorite teachers of all time at
elementary school at Galen Clark your
top over there on the right there that's
maybe that kid sort of peering over the
shoulder trying to trying to figure out
what's going on this special look there
if you can see you can't we can't get
close on that what are you doing there I
I'm being nosy and being curious trying
to figure out what this is all about as
opposed to paying attention when mrs.
Mars is telling us that we should be
paying attention to what's going on you
say that the school's classes that you
had were mostly blacks and Hispanics
right Ronnie White's in his class very
few our town was a classic southern town
but was in the West Mercia at that time
when I grew up when I was going to
Weaver that's the first elementary
school and then to Galen Clark as you
can see and I wish I could see the list
of names the children in that picture
were invariably black and Chicano one or
two whites who happen to be poor and you
can see the amazing mound of racial
concentration what we call South Merced
our community is actually separated by a
railroad track there was a railroad
track between the south and the north
side of Merced in much of the Commerce
much of the business
high schools were on the north side of
Merced all the businesses were there we
had a thriving little urban community
but it was self-sufficient no one came
to Merced South Side to buy things to do
business it was the place where blacks
and browns lived you talk about
affirmative action in your book a lot
right are you an affirmative action
person I am I am Exhibit A I'm an
affirmative action baby I would never
ever deny that I think that two things
first of all just in terms of being able
to have these opportunities I did well
in high school did well in college had
I've been very good as a student what's
interesting is that before I went to
Stanford Stanford had never found a
black person from my high school to go
because they weren't looking I'm not the
first qualified but they just weren't
looking and I know that because I know
that there are other people who could
have excelled and beyond that not only
affirmative action was important to make
sure that it was a consideration but I
was rare a black kid from Merced
California going to Stanford University
there a lot of whites fair number women
there were no other people of color
going and in any real way from from that
community so how did it work it works
exceptionally well I mean what was
amazing that I met my wife there Pam and
up in Baltimore but she went to Compton
high school and she and her classmates
Michelle Miller and Billy Walker were
all the top students at Compton high
school
Rick Turner who's a Dean at the
University of Virginia was at Stanford
then and he recruited all of us and he
would find he what Rick did he was meant
as a genius he would find these these
little diamonds in the rough and these
either rural or urban areas and tell
them about the opportunity to come to a
place like Stanford and so we took
Stanford by storm but how did you get
there to Stanford I mean well who did
somebody reach out and go around this is
an embarrassing story Stanford was the
me respects an accident when I was ready
to look at colleges I had decided that
there was a very nice
College in Southern California went to
go to Occidental why cuz they had the
best brochure very flashy brochure mrs.
Jackson was my counselor and she said
Charles you shouldn't be going to
accidental you should be going to
Stanford I'm a smart cat mr. Jackson I'm
not gonna go to Stanford I don't want to
go all the way to Connecticut I don't
like the cold weather I'm gonna go to
Occidental and she started just laughing
hysterically and then she looked at me
said Charles Stanford's not in
Connecticut it's right here in
California it's two hours north of
Merced I was embarrassed I was
completely embarrassed I heard of
Harvard I've heard of these oh I never
heard of Stanford didn't know it was a
major private institution didn't know
anything about it really didn't know
anyone who had gone until she shared
that with me and so I was embarrassed to
go and apply and visit the school and it
was love at first sight it was a
different thing I had my own bed
I had three meals a day I had a whole
lot of friends I had it was a totally
different environment when I showed up
there it was the other black students
when I told us from Merced we had people
from Chicago and New York from Texas a
lot from Southern California
Reggie Turner good friend right from
East Palo Alto blend net words from
Atlanta and that they asked me where are
you from I said from Merced and they
said is that someplace in the South they
didn't know they'd never heard of the
people in California anywhere else so I
looked like and sounded like I was as
from the as deep in the south as one
could imagine so it made I made it clear
that I was going to do my work
get things done and I had three
outstanding years there graduate in
three years stayed on my fourth year to
get my master's degree and then decide
it was time to do something else the
back says words affirmative action did
somebody say Charles Ogletree we want
you because you're black no I mean was
where did you benefit personally from
affirmative action I am for two reasons
one is that the places like Stanford
said that we want a diverse group of
students not everyone who looks the same
in Stanford looked all white for a very
long time
it's not that there weren't blacks will
qualify they just weren't looking for
them so Stanford started looking for
diversity that is we want to find people
who are otherwise qualified but who are
diverse number one and number two
african-americans had a history of past
discrimination and institutions that is
that there they were there were actual
roadblocks
Stanford is not nearly as guilty as so
many other institutions that had
explicit policies and explicit plans to
keep blacks and others out Jews
particularly a lot of schools had quotas
to keep Jews from attending or other
barriers but the idea of us having
somebody african-american made a
difference that is that they wanted to
find among all the qualified people
people who also happen to be people who
were diverse and so there never was a
sign on my door saying you're a black
student or that you're an affirmative
action admit they said that you still
have to perform like everyone else to
get in here you still have to take every
single exam to pass and you still have
to meet all the requirements to leave
here and that's exactly what I did
graduating Phi Beta Kappa in three years
now this picture right here is from
where oh boy that's my graduation at
Stanford June 1975 it's a bittersweet
occasion because we learned that spring
as we're about to graduate that the
president the university had selected
Daniel Moynihan as a commencement
speaker we were troubled by that because
dentalman dunya moana hadn't liked the
melting pot and other things that we
thought were disparaging in some
respects of african-american families
that particularly for American mothers
and we thought many of us by then my
mother and father had been separated
were divorced by 1975 and there are a
number of single parents who had raised
many of the young people who were there
at Stanford with me and and we thought
our parents had done well and we didn't
think it was an appropriate way for us
to celebrate our most important day in
life that is graduating from Stanford to
Moynihan is a symbol and so what we did
we wrote our parents we black suit and
sat down and put together led and told
our parents to come to Stanford we're
going to have a separate graduation
because we wanted them to appreciate
what they had done their sacrifices they
came a day early
we had Sinclair Drake who was my mentor
and advisor he was a professor who had
been a ruler at university he'd written
the book called black metropolis great
man often had a cigarette in his hand
riding the bicycle across the Stanford
campus a pen Africanist one of my great
heroes he spoke that night Saturday
night to our parents and talked about
how important it was and he talked about
his friends like Kwame and Cora he
talked like Julis in your area who's the
president of Tanzania talked about
Africa and the Diaspora and we told our
parents with something else you should
know that tomorrow is our graduation
it's the most important day for us but
we should let you know that we're not
happy
the Daniel Moynihan is speaking because
we think that does not respect you and
we know you've come here to see us
graduate but we're going to march out
we're not going to be disrespectful
we're not going to be disruptive we're
not going to demonstrate we're going to
be very obedient but when Daniel
Moynihan gets up to speak we plan to get
up and March out we simply want you to
know that and our parents to our
surprise after a lot of tears and
sadness and and happiness that we
understand it and you go ahead and do
that and so just as he was introduced we
got up and we started walking out and
then Chicano students start walking down
and then I saw Richard Kelly Richard
Kelly is a seven foot one white
basketball player on the Stanford
basketball team and rich got up and
walked out a good friend of mine and
then the parents went out and when I was
going out there was a woman who told me
a black woman said his son helped me out
I didn't know who she was it turned out
her name was Ruby Edwards she was the
grandmother of Belinda at words from
Atlanta and I said no this is you have
to do this she said no son just help me
out and her point was that
she'd marched with dr. King down south
she had made great sacrifices she was
not going to let her dog or
granddaughter's graduation be damaged by
having us feel less than whole and so
she said that I fought against different
types of prejudice in the south and I'm
gonna do it right here in the West and
she helped me let me help her carry out
and it was a proud moment of my life to
not just be going out but to have this
Civil Rights icon who marched with dr.
King becoming a part of it and at that
moment it made me realize that we were
we arrived we we had grown to a level of
maturity to understand that is not just
enough to go to these institutions and
get the great education we have to make
sacrifices and we have to reach back
whenever we make it over the threshold
we have to reach back and bring others
with us and it's not about a hand out
it's a hand up lifting people up and
that was that that has been the theme of
the book the theme of my store we have
to uplift and lift up others because
we've been uplifted and lifted up our
entire lives let me ask you first did
you indicated in the book that they
still have a black graduation ceremony
the day before at Stanford it's
interesting the students who are doing
this at Stanford now had no idea why
they're doing the acceptance a
celebration on Sarah they call it the
baccalaureate ceremony it's not just
african-americans but as Native
Americans as Hispanics and as Asian
Americans they all have a baccalaureate
where they have a ceremony the
african-american students there are over
a thousand people there because there's
a large number of parents grandparents
aunts and uncles and sometimes siblings
and friends who come and they feel the
entire Memorial Church and it's a very
emotional ceremony because for most of
these families its first the first
person graduating college it's still the
first in the year 2003 or 2004 we
haven't made that much progress that
there are a lot of legacies
second-generation insult and the
ceremony begins with us when the student
is graduating they stand up and either a
sibling or a child sometimes or a parent
or a grandparent will come up and put a
Kinte cloth around them it's sort of the
rites of passage it's what you'd call it
and it's funny I spoke a few years ago
at one of the ceremonies and it's
amazing because the students have no
idea that this celebration was an
original protest it was a challenge to
the sense of not being considered worthy
of having a speaker that reflected the
diversity of what that Stanford student
body showed and so it's sort of humorous
now that they have these sessions in a
popular way and then because they get
lost I mean all these students at least
for the grandparents when you Stanford
has thousands of people graduating John
Smith doesn't mean anything in a crowd
of thousands but here if you're one of
200 and you have a moment of recognition
there's a whole booklet put together
it's that one little recognition doing
something very special at a place like
Stanford and let me also say people say
oh that's the segregation and that's
that well this is these students we are
still in a predominantly white
institution we still are required and
must meet every academic challenge
that's there and we still go into the
world we're not black doctors or black
lawyers or black teachers we're doctors
lawyers teachers and business leaders
having received first-rate education and
so it's a sense of having a little bit
of community at one hand but then been
part of a larger community at the same
head and Stanford celebrates all of its
minority alumni 2004 with a major
gathering to come back and examine how
much people have progress people like
Jerry Yang a head of Yahoo was a
Stanford graduate mae Jemison who was
the first African American woman to go
on to as an astronaut to Stanford
graduate Laurie hfst who was the deaf
the chief of staff for President Clinton
Rick West who runs the Native American
Museum here in Washington DC these are
among the sort of Giants to show the
diversity and excellence that you know
that they're interchangeable and not in
conflict and the one thing I want to say
I actually mentioned it in the book
about this because a lot of people keep
thinking of affirmative action as a
reflection of inequality or substandard
in the Michigan case hours of the recent
Michigan Michigan case in 2003 the
Supreme Court case on diversity in front
of action even Chief Justice Rehnquist
realized what was at stake this is not
about under-qualified as sub par
students what he said in that case was
this the university has considered
african-americans Hispanics and Native
Americans to be underrepresented
minorities and admits virtually every
qualified applicant from these groups
qualified I don't know a place in
America where you can say I'm black let
me in I'm black
give me a job I'm black give me a
promotion it doesn't happen that way and
when I first saw the word qualified
applicant I said why you could qualify
that because that is exactly what it
requires and I think part of the myth is
that people focus on certain aspects
whether it's a an achievement test or
other factors but my colleague at the
Harvard School of Education Howard
Gardner has written an amazing book
talks about people should be judged by
what he calls multiple excellencies it's
not just how you perform on a test you
can be artistic you can be collaborative
you can have a whole host of skills and
talents and those all contribute to the
wholeness of a person and to the
collective strength of a group and
that's what diversity is about you don't
want a football team with 11
quarterbacks and no lineman you don't
want a basketball team with all guards
and no sinners you want people with
different strengths different skills
different responsibilities and together
it's a much stronger unit and a much
more productive unit and even there
Brian wouldn't without you I was started
when I wrote this book to look at the
mission case a little careful more
carefully my classmate John Payton from
Harvard Law School argued the case he
won
in the district court he won in the
Sixth Circuit he won the Supreme Court
and John was able to put together this
incredible data that showed that the
majority of the black students and the
majority of the white students who
attend the University of Michigan come
from segregated high schools that is if
you're black
most of those black students come from
black schools and most of the whites
come from white schools it means the
first opportunity that many of these
children have had to see someone
different than them is in college we
can't be the United States of America we
cannot be a diverse nation and have
people go through 18 formative years and
never encounter someone different from
them that's exactly what Charles
Hamilton Houston Thurgood Marshall bill
Coleman Constance Baker motley Robert
Carter's couple spots was Robinson
that's what they fought for they just
wanted to say we are better as a nation
if we all come together in some way and
create a much stronger United States of
America and that's what this book is
about yeah not much time of it let me go
back to something that and you know you
get an argument on this that you have a
special graduation for black yes or
Native Americans whatever will the day
come where you will no longer need a
Black Student Union on a campus oh
absolutely
when do you think that will happen I
hope it happens in my lifetime there's a
very interesting book that was written
about justice Powell when the Supreme
quotes in the Bakke case in 1978 and
maybe getting the two parties wrong but
justice Powell's thought was that the
whole issue of complete diversity and
complete integration could happen in ten
years
just as Marshall said no it will take a
century this is 1978 when the Bakke case
has occurred in 1978 when I was
finishing Harvard Law School I thought
it would happen in 25 years I thought by
now we would be there but we aren't I
think that justice O'Connor has written
an opinion in the in the Michigan
affirmative action cases saying that she
hopes that and 25 years from now that is
in the year 2028 that there would no
longer be a need for these affirmative
action programs I hope she's right I
have just
appointed to be the director of a new
Institute at Harvard called the Charles
Hamilton Houston Racing Justice
Institute and one of the first things I
plan to do is to take up what I call the
O'Connor project I want to seriously
examine which social scientists and
other experts to what extent can we
pursue justice O'Connor's challenge
let's try to make the issue of race less
necessary I know I'm going up against
the fact that we're more cigarette and
now than we were before we have 40 and
50 percent dropout rates of African
Americans and Hispanics and many of our
urban areas we have lower health care in
the african-american community than some
third world countries we still have what
people call predatory lending that
African Americans have to pay more when
they're getting loans can't move into
certain neighborhoods my daughter
Rashida worked for a fair housing agency
would send black couples out in the 21st
century in year 2000 they would be told
that no apartments available and then a
white couple will come back ten minutes
later this is year 2000 2001 and they
could they get the same apartment and so
I know as much as we've made progress as
much as I and others have made it over
we still have those problems so this
institute will allow us to do what all
of us want I want to do what Thurgood
Marshall wanted I wanted to do with
Charles help to do so what I want us to
have a colorblind and a race-neutral
society we're not there yet but I'm
hopeful that we will be there in my
lifetime this is the cover of the book
we're talking about Brown versus the
Board of Education in 50 years later
Charles J Ogletree jr. our guest it's
called all deliberate speed and we thank
you for your time thank you where I
appreciate it